graveelaxe de carpe au praliné de
noisette huile de crisson et glace à la
betterê rave si l'intitulé fait salivé
il est surtout 100 % mine Loiré dans
cette assiette que des produits locaux
et de saison c'est une démarche qu'on a
régulièrement au lycée on a une classe
en première qui est basée sur le circuit
court uniquement donc des élèves avec un
enseignant qui vont découvrir des
producteurs voilà c'est c'est vraiment
une démarche qu'on essaie de d'inclure
dans le lycée tout au long de l'année
ces apprentis cuisiniers ont prévu de
présenter une entrée et un plat depuis
le début du mois il paaufine les
recettes et surtout le dressage de leur
création
technique par qu'il faut rester bien fin
que ce soit bien régulier pour qu'on a
l'assiette l'assiette so uniforme il y a
toujours l'effet un peu l'ffet wa comme
on appelle quoi de pouvoir découvrir de
belles assiettes c'est un peu ce qu'on
recherche aussi dans un con le jour J
ils auront 3 heur pour tout réaliser
pour certains ce sera leur premier
concours il y a un peu de stress mais on
va dire que le fait d'être avec les
collègues qui sont à la fois les copains
ça ça rassure quand d'autres comme Paul
préparent en même temps celui de
meilleur apprentis de
France ça met un peu de stress en plus
et et si on peut gérer de concours en
même temps derrière on peut tout gérer
pour le plat de résistance une volaille
de l'orléané garni à la butternut et ses
échalotes aux champignons sauvages si
l'un des deux plats obtient les faveurs
du jury il pourra aussi franchir les
frontières du
concours on a tout lieu de penser que
c'est les plats qui seront choisis entré
plat dessert se retrouent sur les tbles
des restaurateurs Loir étetin et
également dans les collèges ou
restaurations collective de tous ordres
il reste un peu plus d'un mois avant de
se confronter aux autres brigades du
département le 25 novembre au salon de
la gastronomie
d'Orléan